[Music]
they say the pen is mightier than the
sword
and authorities have often agreed from
outlawed religious tracts and
revolutionary manifestos to censored and
burned books we know the potential power
of words to overturn the social order
but as strange as it may seem some
numbers have also been considered
dangerous enough to ban our distant
ancestors long counted objects using
simple tally marks but as they developed
agriculture and begin living together in
larger groups this was no longer enough
as numbers grew more complex people
began not just using them but thinking
about what they are and how they work
and by 600 BCE in ancient Greece the
study of numbers was well developed the
mathematician Pythagoras and his school
of followers found numerical patterns in
shapes music and the Stars for them
mathematics held the deepest secrets of
the universe
but one Pythagorean named hipa sious
discovered something disturbing some
quantities like the diagonal of a square
with sides of length 1 couldn't be
expressed by any combination of whole
numbers or fractions no matter how small
these numbers which we call irrational
numbers were perceived as a threat to
the pythagoreans notion of a perfect
universe
they imagined a reality that could be
described with rational numerical
patterns historians write that HIPAA sis
was exiled for publicizing his findings
while legends claim he was drowned as
punishment from the gods
while irrational numbers upset
philosophers later mathematical
inventions would draw attention from
political and religious authorities as
well in the Middle Ages while Europe was
still using Roman numerals other
cultures had developed positional
systems that included a symbol for zero
when Arab travelers brought the system
to the bustling maritime cities of Italy
its advantages for merchants and bankers
was clear but the authorities were more
wary hindu-arabic numerals were
considered easier to forge or alter
especially since they were less familiar
to customers than to merchants and the
concept of zero opened the door to
negative numbers and the recording of
debt at a time when money lending was
regarded with suspicion in the 13th
century Florence banned the use of
hindu-arabic numerals for record-keeping
and though they soon proved too useful
to ignore controversies over 0 and
negative numbers continued for a long
time negative numbers were dismissed as
absurd well into the 19th century and
prominent mathematicians like Gerolamo
Cardano avoided using zero even though
it would have made it much easier to
find solutions to cubic and quartic
equations even today it's illegal to use
some numbers for different reasons
some are banned because of what they
represent
for example governments have prohibited
the display of numbers that have
symbolic meaning such as the date of a
revolution or connections to
oppositional political figures or
parties other numbers are potentially
illegal because of the information they
carry just about any information whether
text image video or executable programs
can be translated into a string of
numbers
but this means that protected
information whether copyrights
proprietary materials or state secrets
can also be represented as numbers so
possessing or publishing these numbers
may be treated as a criminal offense
this idea gathered attention in 2001
when code that could be used to decrypt
DVDs was widely shared and distributed
in the form of a large prime number
the idea of illegal numbers may sound
absurd but like words written numbers
are a way of expressing concepts and
information and in a world where
calculations and algorithms shape more
and more of our lives the mathematicians
pencil grows stronger by the day did you
enjoy this lesson if so please consider
supporting our nonprofit mission by
visiting patreon.com slash ted Edie
[Music]